[تصفيق] انتشرت لعبة القفز
بالحبل على الإنستغرام وكنت أشعر بالفضول كيف
تحولت هذه اللعبة للأطفال إلى جنون لياقة بدنية سريع جدًا ،
حيث بدأت لورين فلايمان القفز
العام الماضي وكانت تنشر رحلتها على
الإنستغرام ، فقد انتقلت من مبتدئة
إلى هذه السرعة  freestyler ،
ما الذي يعجبك في القفز بالحبال ، إنه
شيء
يمكن لأي شخص أن يتعلمه ، ليس من الصعب جدًا
أن
يشعر بأنه مستحيل تمامًا ولكنه أيضًا
يمثل تحديًا ، لذا
فهو يعمل حقًا في عقلك ، كما أن
حبال القفز بالجسم هو أحد أكثر
تمارين القلب كفاءة ويبدو
مثل الكثير من المرح أيضًا ،
لذا قررت أن أجربها ، ما هي
نصيحتك للمبتدئين ،
لذا اختر أولًا الحبل المناسب ،
سيكون من الصعب جدًا تعلم الحبل السلكي
لأنه يتحرك بسرعة كبيرة ،
فأنت تريد شيئًا لا يفعل ذلك.
يتحرك بسرعة كبيرة ،
وهو مطرز بالخرز هو المفضل لدي ، وهذا هو
الحبل المزيّن بالخرز
، وهو في الأساس لديك هذه التي أستخدم
سرعات خرز بوصة واحدة توفر بشكل أساسي
مزيدًا من التعليقات
التي يمكنك الشعور بها وسماع الحبل
تتحرك من
حولك حتى تعرف متى تقفز ، الخطوة الأولى ،
تحقق الثانية هي طول الحبل ،
تأكد من
أن حبلك طويل بما يكفي بحيث يمسح
قدميك عند القفز ولكن ليس لفترة طويلة
بحيث يكون هناك الكثير من الحبل يصطدم
بالأرض بدون
يجب أن يصل الحبل
إلى أسفل صدرك في مكان ما
بين هناك وسرة بطنك
ومن المحتمل أن يكون المبتدئ
في الطرف العلوي من ذلك
الآن حان الوقت لتعلم الارتداد الأساسي
لطرفها الثالث وهو ضبط الحبل لأسفل
والممارسة  بالشكل الصحيح
الذي تقفز فيه منخفضًا على الأرض ، فأنت
على أصابع قدميك ، يجب ألا تدع
كعبك يلمس الأرض في أي وقت
يجب ألا تركل قدميك للخلف ،
فأنت تريد أن تبقي ركبتيك مرتخيتين ولكن
ساقيك  بشكل مستقيم إلى حد كبير ، مجرد
انحناء طفيف في الركبة
، اقترحت أيضًا أن تهز يديك
كما لو كنت تهز الماء عنها
، ونعم أشعر بالسخرية تمامًا من
القيام بذلك ، لكن من الأفضل الحصول على
الشكل الآن قبل أن يتم
جلدك بالحبل.
أكره خطوة بخطوة للحصول على ارتدادك الأساسي
لا
تتوقع أن تكون قادرًا على القيام بالكثير من القفزات
المتتالية دون
التعثر ونتوقع أن يتم جلدك قليلاً ، إنه
أمر طبيعي جدًا
لنبدأ ببعض القفزات الأساسية
التي بدأت في ممارستها كل صباح و
هذا هو المكان الذي تأتي فيه نصيحتها التالية في
متناول يديك ،
لا تفعل الكثير في وقت مبكر جدًا كمبتدئ
عندما تبدأ ،
لا يجب أن تفعل أكثر من
خمس إلى عشر دقائق في كل مرة
وإلا ستواجه إصابات الإفراط في الاستخدام ،
كان هذا هو الأسهل  قاعدة يجب اتباعها
لأنها مرهقة بعد دقيقتين
من قفز الحبل ، كنت بحاجة لالتقاط
أنفاسي ،
حسنًا ، هل تم كسرها ، كنت أتعلم
الارتداد الأساسي وأنا مستعد
لمواجهة بعض تحديات المبتدئين
بمجرد أن تتقن الارتداد الأساسي
يمكنك الانتقال إلى أشياء مثل
عمليات الانتقال
ثم التأرجحات الجانبية وأيضًا
خطوات الملاكم التي لا تزال على قدميك
ولكنك تنقل وزنك
بين كل واحدة بعد أسابيع من التدريب ،
علمت أن حبال القفز بالحبل
قاسي  r مما
يبدو ، استغرق الأمر مني بعض الوقت للدخول في
تأرجح الأشياء ولكن ببطء أصبحت الحيل
أسهل وأسهل ،
وفي النهاية كنت أقوم بتسمير عمليات الانتقال
ثم أصبحت مدمنًا ، فإن
سجلي هو ستة على التوالي
عندما تحصل على المهارات.
من الرائع أن تكون قادرًا على القيام بشيء
يبدو وكأنه مرضٍ
لك [موسيقى]